why don't we go next to oh I don't know
how about uh Adrian from San Francisco
Adrian from San Francisco welcome to the
program
thank you David I'm I'm not in the one
in South America
okay right you're in San Francisco
California
that's right how are you David I'm doing
well
David one thing I wanted to discuss with
you today was um a problem of
homelessness in California as a whole I
mean yep our state we've spent over 10
billion dollars in the past four years
on homelessness and oftentimes there's
sort of this perceived dichotomy of well
you can't you have to sacrifice safety
uh for Compassion or the other way
around so given that we spend so much
money but programs seem to be extremely
ineffective what's your take on terms of
number one the strategies to actually
solve this problem and number two why do
you think despite having spent so many
resources today we haven't really done
anything to to help solve or fix this
problem well homelessness is such a
complicated issue so it's interesting
you asked this on the Wednesday show we
covered Donald Trump's video where he
says he will create mandatory tent
cities which homeless people will be
brought to on buses and that's the
couldn't couldn't have a worse uh uh
solution to homelessness you're further
stigmatizing homeless people you're
taking them away from where the jobs are
those tent camps invariably become
overpopulated and sanitation becomes an
issue like that's the totally wrong
approach now what will work there's no
one thing that will work but a few
things that have to be done to deal
effectively with homelessness and part
of you know that you're asking why
hasn't the money spent worked if you
only do like one or two of these things
it doesn't work because you're not
actually solving the problem so we
really have to deal with why people
become homeless to begin with so number
one
affordability of housing housing is
really expensive in California and in
particular in the parts of California
that have the jobs and the people where
most people would try to be so you've
got to increase the availability of
affordable housing how you do it okay
you got to figure that out two expand
access to mental health and substance
abuse treatment have to do it we hear
about oh we're going to do it but like
how exactly do you do it what are the
programs is it properly funded and you
have to make sure people know about them
number three you've got to provide job
training and employment support just
getting you know you create a housing
place and you just give homeless people
housing great but are they actually at a
place where they can get themselves a
job and are they properly trained to
have a job and re-enter uh the workplace
particularly if they've been out of a
job for a decade and have been homeless
for a decade so you got to do the job
training and employment support you
probably need to do something about
folks kind of exiting the criminal
justice system into homelessness there's
like kind of very mediocre halfway
houses but there's lack of stable
housing for people when they exit the
the criminal justice system so that
would be number four and then number
five you probably need more of a social
safety net which which has you know
temporary assistance food stamps
different things need to expand it
probably by uh getting services to more
people like that's a lot of stuff and
it's very easy to say like well we've
done some of that but you really need to
do all of it because homelessness is
such a complicated problem
you're you're absolutely right I agree
on all five of your points David but you
know one of the things that's
frustrating to me as a resident is that
you know the city of San Francisco
spends a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year per homeless person and
so you know the money is there we have
the money and the resources but somehow
it's not actually translating to
anything effective because those people
still need help those people are still
suffering on the streets and so
fundamentally there's this disconnect
where we see we're paying our taxpayer
dollars to try to help these people so
now hold on a second Adrian I'm not
finding that San Francisco spends 120
Grand a year per homeless person what I
am finding is that for the shelter beds
they're 70 grand a year per shelter bed
spent of course not all homeless people
are even participating in the shelter
system that's still a lot of money and
it seems like there's waste there but
I'm not I'm not finding that number that
you're you're pointing out
David is there a way I can later on
provide links or resources so we can
email info davidpackman.com I'll look
into that and listen you're a hundred
percent correct with the general
sentiment Adrian whatever the numbers
are that people's tax money is going
into what you are told or programs meant
to deal with an issue the issue isn't
being dealt with and I'm right there
with you on that whatever the numbers
are
great thanks so much David all right
Adrian from San Francisco
important issue let's take a very quick
break we're going to continue with the
phones in just a moment just hang on if
you're waiting to talk to me and we'll
be right back